all right 6 43 time to see what is
trending with las vegas now host
mercedes martinez and there she is
joining us live from the mix 94.1
studios good morning mercedes
good morning you too first up another
honor for music superstar billy eilish
so check this out she is the latest
artist to be immortalized in wax the
hollywood wax museum revealed her new
wax figure yesterday but
some fans are not happy the general
reaction is that the figure makes the 20
or on the 20 year old look older one
comment even said that it looks like
billy eilish at the age of 50. what do
you think you be the judge meanwhile
speculation remains on who will become
the permanent host of jeopardy now
season 38 it's set to wrap production in
a few weeks and the contracts of both
mayan bialik and ken jennings will
expire then the show's executive
producer says that announcement is
coming
very soon and that the show will need
multiple hosts moving forward john
heather throw your hat in the ring i
think both of you would be great i have
said mercedes for years now that nate
tienebaum should be and always
will be
wonderful
yes
yes agreement
let's switch gears mercedes there's a
new fragrance that's available right now
i am definitely on board with
it's it's sizzling i think is the right
way to describe it mercedes
[Laughter]
that's right it smells like bacon
right bacon they are celebrating their
100th anniversary with a new bacon
scented fragrance it's called
right
100 degrees now the scent features hints
of applewood
bergamot maple syrup among other uh
bacon related smells you can actually
buy the fragrance at wright's website
for a meaty
19.22 cents the year that wright went
into business i know what i'm getting
you for secret santa at channel 8. this
year
and there'll be like a pack of dogs
following him around
yeah all of my in my uh yeah in the
newsroom
what is that what is it
is there what's happening john langler
[Laughter]
later this week